esta gráfica de barras nos representa el
número de bombas de chicle que cada una
de estas cuatro personas hace y lo que
quiero hacer es bueno el primero hallar
la media de del número de bombas de
chicle que se hicieron y luego descubrir
qué tanto se dispersan los datos
respecto a la media y eso lo haremos
calculando la desviación media absoluta
muy bien así que como siempre te invito
a que hagas una pausa y trates de
hacerlo por tu propia cuenta y después
lo hacemos juntos recuerda tienes que
hallar primero la media y después la
desviación media absoluta
muy bien así que vamos a calcular
primero la media muy bien ahí tenemos la
media y como calculamos la media pues
simplemente tenemos que sumar todos los
datos obtenidos y dividirlos entre 4
porque 4 son el número de personas que
estamos considerando verdad entonces por
ejemplo si nos fijamos en los resultados
de diana pues ya no pudo hacer cuatro
bombas de chicle muy bien por otro lado
lourdes pudo hacer una más verdad puedo
hacer cinco bombas de chicle y nuestra
campeona es irina que pudo hacer seis
bombas de chicle en cambio nadie solo
pudo hacer una bomba de chicle verdad y
si ahora todos es éste está suma la
dividimos entre cuatro podemos obtener
la media muy bien y esto es algo muy
sencillo verdad 45 son 99 más 6 son 15 y
15 más 1 son 16 que si lo dividimos
entre 4 nos da exactamente 4 así que
es exactamente 4 y de hecho podríamos
marcarlo por aquí que aquí está la media
más o menos aquí podemos verlo
gráficamente ok ahí tenemos justamente
la media y ahora con esta información
nosotros ya podríamos tratar de calcular
cuál es la desviación media absoluta y
que vamos a denotar la como dm a verdad
desviación media absoluta y recordemos
que esto se calcula como el promedio de
las desviaciones absolutas verdad
entonces vamos a vamos a tratar de ver
cómo se ve esto exactamente muy bien
vamos a ver aquí vamos a poner por
ejemplo la desviación absoluta de cada
una de estas chicas o del número de
bombas de chicle que cada una de ellas
pudo hacer entonces si nos fijamos por
ejemplo en los resultados de diana pues
no hay ninguna desviación respecto al
promedio verdad aquí no hay desviación
justamente hizo cuatro y coincide con
que el promedio es 4 así que hay 0 como
su desviación absoluta ahora bien si nos
fijamos en el resultado de lourdes pues
tenemos que lourdes tuvo una desviación
de una de una bomba verdad una
de chicle tenemos solo una bomba de
chicle como desviación respecto a la
media si nos fijamos ahora en el
resultado de irina ella tiene una
desviación de 2 tiene una desviación de
2 están dos por arriba del promedio de
la media verdad entonces tenemos un 2 y
finalmente si nos fijamos en el
resultado de nadine tenemos que ella
tiene una desviación de 3 respecto a la
media por supuesto aquí a lo mejor uno
podría pensar que que importa ir hacia
arriba o hacia abajo pero en realidad no
para calcular la desviación media
absoluta solo necesitamos saber el
número de digamos pasos o de saltos que
el cual se desvía de la media verdad en
este caso no nos importa si va para
arriba o para abajo así que la
desviación media absoluta se calcula
como la suma de todas estas desviaciones
absolutas dividida entre el número de
datos así que tenemos cero para diana
tenemos uno para lourdes
2 para harina y tenemos 3 para nadie y
dividimos entre 4 que es el número de
datos y si nos fijamos tenemos 0 + 1 es
uno más dos son tres más tres son seis
así que la desviación media absoluta es
de seis cuartos y que nosotros incluso
podríamos representarlo de distintas
formas por ejemplo esto es lo mismo que
tres medios también podríamos decir que
es un entero un medio o también
podríamos decir simplemente que es 1.5
verdad son tres formas distintas de
decir exactamente lo mismo y entonces
tenemos que esto es una medida el 1.5 es
una medida de que tanto varían estos
datos con respecto a la media verdad y
algunos pensarán que bueno
a lo mejor les han enseñado que hay una
fórmula para la desviación media
absoluta a lo mejor es una fórmula muy
complicada o qué sé yo y a lo mejor no
estás tan seguro de que hayamos
calculado la desviación como como la
fórmula dice pero en realidad así lo
hicimos y es una
y lo hicimos con una forma muy elegante
viéndolo a través de nuestra gráfica
verdad así que ahora vamos a hacerlo con
la fórmula para que este es muy obtengas
la confianza de que no hemos hecho nada
malo aunque entonces si calculamos la
desviación media absoluta en realidad
hay que calcular por ejemplo los valores
el valor absoluto de las diferencias con
respecto a la media verdad en este caso
diana tuvo un 4 y hay que restarle la
media verdad esta es la desviación
absoluta de diana la desviación absoluta
de lourdes sería 4 no perdón sería ella
obtuvo cinco menos cuatro verdades su
desviación absoluta la desviación
absoluta de irina es 6 menos 4 y
recuerden que todo esto lleva a los
valores absolutos
la desviación de nadine que es uno menos
cuatro verdad y recordemos aquí que este
4 es en realidad la media que estamos
calculando la desviación respecto a la
media muy bien y luego dividimos entre
el número de datos que en este caso son
4 entonces si nos fijamos por ejemplo
por ejemplo en el primer dato tenemos 4
menos 4 esto nos da 0 verdad que justo
corresponde con este 0 que teníamos aquí
arriba por ejemplo podríamos ver que 5
menos 4 en realidad nos da 1 y que
corresponde con este 1 que tenemos
arriba por ejemplo tenemos 6 menos 4 que
nos da 2 que corresponde a este 2 que
tenemos aquí arriba y finalmente tenemos
1 menos cuatro verdad que es menos 3
pero con valor absoluto es 3 que
corresponde justamente a este 3 que
tenemos arriba entonces esencialmente
estamos haciendo las mismas operaciones
y por lo tanto nos debe dar el mismo
resultado así que espero
con este vídeo hayas visto que la
desviación media absoluta es fácil y
además es muy pero muy interesante